بعد ان اكتملت اركان الخطه غادرت تروم
منزله في فلوريدا تحت الاضواء
بث مباشر على كل القنوات ومئات الانصار في
الشوارع لتحيته اقامته في نيويورك كانت
محسوبه بالدقيقه اما خطواته المتثاقله
التي قادته الى القاضي فقد كانت جزءا من
بروفه تفاصيلها اعدت مسبقا مصدر من داخل
البيت اكد ان المتهمه ناقشه طويلا مع
دفاعه السلوك الامثل اثناء المحاكمه
تعابير الوجه ولغه الجسد كانت كلها تصب في
اتجاه مشهد واحد الضحيه والجلاد
ايام بعدها جاء دور الاخراج تروم نشر مقطع
فيديو يروي في اقل من دقيقه قصه رئيس سابق
خضع للقانون رغم براءته المسبقه
[موسيقى]
المقطع شاهده الملايين وبات واجهه الحمله
الانتخابيه ترامب المترشح يتجه تدريجيا
لاستهداف مشاعر سكان وسط امريكا ضد
البرياليه واشنطن ونيويورك
اما انصاره فقد ازداد تشددا خاصه بعد ان
انتصر في قضيه اخرى امام ستورمي دانييلز
بعيدا عن نيويورك محكمه كاليفورنيا الزمت
الممثله الاباحيه دفع مبلغ قدره 600 الف
دولار تعويضا عن بطلان ادعاءها بالتعرض
للتهديد
استغل القضيه والطالب بالمزيد من اموال
المتبرعين اكثر من ثمانيه ملايين دولار
جمعت فقط لدعمه امام القضاء لكن العوده
للبيت الابيض مشروع يلتهم المال دون حساب
تحول محاكمه منهتا الى دعايه انتخابيه لم
يعد مساله جدليه في امريكا لكن قدره ترونب
على استماله الاصوات المتارجحه تحدي اخر
يلزمه تقمص دور المنقذ لا ضحيه يجر وراءه
المشاكل
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات